hello everyone and welcome to the Primus
it's only round seven of the very strong
1936 international tournament in Moscow
but this is basically the clash everyone
wants to see its Mikhail Botvinnik
versus Jose roll capablanca and before
we check out the game we do have a nice
photo challenge so as usual it's twofold
for one point who is the Grandmaster on
the right end for an additional point
who is the person accompanying him on
the left
best of luck to everyone and now let's
check out the game and we also have a
photo of this encounter now I believe
this is a photo of this encounter
between hood the white pieces against
kappa blanka from 1936 in moscow after
some research I did you know I found to
believe that this is this photo it is of
poor quality but it is 1936 so we can't
really afford to be picky and I've seen
that some sources also use this photo
for the 1938 Avro tournament but I
believe this is the 1936 Moscow
tournament and from the game you know
kappa blanka holding his head it does
appear to beat this game so let's check
it out
both wink has the white pieces and he
opens a twit knight to f3
so the ready Knight to f6 c4 we go into
the English II 6 g3 b6 and Bishop to g2
both players can get over there light
square bishop so we have castles c5 and
b3 botnik preparing to Fein care to the
other Bishop as well Knight to c6 Bishop
to b2 brush up to e7 Knight to c3 a
couple Blanca castles and d4 botanique
wants to see either a cover Blanca will
exchange a lot of pieces now or he will
he will push d5 he could push d5 and
then after C captures pawn captures will
go III and this is also very much
playable but after d4 Capablanca is is a
much more experienced player of course
even though botanique is very strong
kappa blanka doesn't think about any can
handle this position against him in in a
simplified version so Knight captures on
e4 Knight captures Bishop captures King
captures pawn cap person before Queen
captures on d4 and now Queen to c7
we have efore by both eunuch
and the material on the board is equal
both players have bishop night and queen
in the game two rooks are basically
undeveloped but Cup botanique squeeze a
queen is a much more active than Cup
along as Queen and c7 also botanique has
this very nice battery Bushell queen ing
seven maybe in the future so couple
Blanca will have to be very careful
about that
rook 888 capablanca would very much
enjoy getting either exchanging we're
pushing his D pawn as it's a it's a
backwards pawn it's a weak point so you
do have to do something about it if you
simply a lot about you need to pile up
on it you're just gonna lose it so we
have looked at e1 about unique is now
preparing to occupy the D file Queen to
b7 now perhaps threatening d5 in some
variations we have f3 adding further
protection to the e4 pawn and now nice
to e8 98 a very nice idea may be
preparing moves like Bishop to f6 the
the pawn may now come to d6 also the
night for me it is guarding g7 so this
Knight cannot do any discoveries and
threaten checkmate on g7 so a a very
nice idea by capablanca we have worked
to d2 Botvinnik prepares to double up on
the D file and now as this this rook is
now very poorly placed it's not a very
active but this was couple Blancas idea
he wants to activate it via f5 and he
plays this rook F to d1 Botvinnik
doubles up on the D file we have Bishop
to g5 attacking the rook and here rope
to d3 you could push a for take the bush
back but then you're just opening up
opening up your teen maybe a bit too
much so after Bishop to g5 we have
looked to d3
getting the rook out of the attack the
bishop to f6 attacking the Queen and E 5
now Bishop to e7
threatening ideas like a Bishop to c5 so
we have Queen back to f2 and now comes
route to f7 as the d the d7 phone will
come under heavy fire so kappa blanka
prepares to defend it Queen to d2 now
with tripling his forces on the D file
and now Bishop to b4 pinning this Knight
but also opening up
a protection of the d7 point from the
rook on f7 I will have a three trying to
figure out either kappa blanka will
capture the night or go back but of
course the bishop is far too valuable to
trade it for this night so Bishop back
to F say there so back to f8 and now
nice - e - nice the b5 also seems like a
very nice idea when I'll bring the
knight all all the way to d6 but after a
sex attacking it might be six black will
simply capture it
mushroom captures and after pawn
captures this does a you know really
stifle blacks position but after Knight
to f6 the other Luke is coming here you
can simply pull the pawn black black
will have a very decent game so botany
he doesn't want to force anything he
plays nice to eat - nice to see seven
and now Knight comes to f4 and now it's
an either for is a very active square
for the knight you don't want to push
something like g5 opening up your
position too much and now the c7 knight
is pinned as you can't move it because
Knight captures on e6 is coming so we
have g 6h for bible tuning and now b5
Capablanca has to try something we have
pawn captures Queen captures on b5 and
now rook the c1 attacking the knight on
c7 as we've said you cannot move the
knight because Knight captures on e6 is
a huge threat we have Queen to b7 and
the Queen to b7 was actually a mistake
by Capablanca and here both eunuch
immediately seizes the opportunity and
plays rook captures on c7 he wants to
take down capablanca with fireworks if
he if he took her you know a couple of
minutes more considering this move he
would have found the very simple and
calm Queen to a5 now notice that there
is a double attack on the c7 night and
you still can't move the knight because
of Knight captures here and also the
queen is now attacking the rook and yet
that is undefended
your only way of defending this is rook
to c8
but now comes Luke D - C 3 with a triple
attack on the night you can't move the
knight once again so your only way of
defending your position is pushing the
deep on either d6 or d5 doesn't really
matter after it would be 5 ok the rook
is now protecting the night
now comes the night captures on e6 and
blacks position is is pretty much done
for you now have no longer any options
your knight is attacked four times you
have to capture the night and then out
comes rook captures on c8 you win the
exchange and you know you have to play
this position on but chances are you
will win this position would white the
old Robotnik would definitely found
Queen to a5 but the younger Botvinnik
obviously wanted fireworks on the board
to take down couple Blanca so he played
rook captures on c7 now of course Queen
captures on c7 and as the exponent is no
longer defended by the night now comes
Knight captures on e6 doesn't matter if
you move the Queen that's even worse you
have to capture the Knights all pawn
captures and now comes rogue captures on
b8 we have f4 a very nice move by a
couple Blanca so notice that in this
position kappa blanka botanique is not
up the exchange he is only up a pawn but
now he will have to use a lot of time to
decipher this position as couple Blanca
plays f4 so what do you do here
obviously you don't want to capture so G
for now Capablanca plays King Queen to
e7 a very nice idea first attacking the
h4 pawn either of trying to provoke g5
from Botvinnik or King 2 H 3 g5 would
have been better but it's very hard to
understand why G if I would have been
better about any place Queen to h3 and
the now Capablanca goes Queen to b7 now
attacking the b3 pawn and also the f3
pawn one of the reasons why g5 was
better in that position
Queen to d3 only moved that defense both
pawns and now comes King to g7 on
pinning and now the bishop can become
active before you don't want the b3
point to be to be a target and now a5
either either getting rid of one point
but you know mainly creating a weakness
on the Queen side b5 and now a for not
allowing both eunuchs to push a form
himself and solidify the Queen side pawn
structure
g5 now we have Bishop to c5 and here
comes Rock to d6 rook to d6 is a very
nice
botany of course if you capture then
pawn captures will create a very nice
past born and also open up a discovery
from the bishop to the king and well
this is a very nice idea
botany should have prepared it with King
to g2 simply a slight improvement in the
position the king is now guarding the f3
pawn so the Queen no longer has to stay
on d3 but it seems that young Botvinnik
was was very hasty in those days he
immediately played rook to be 6 and now
capablanca can actually capture the rook
Bishop captures we have pawn captures
disk opening up a discover check from
the bishop to the King King goes to f8
and now with Queen to c3 the game is
very much still playable for white
botanique immediately threatens Queen to
h8 checkmate and black has to struggle
very hard to keep playing this game but
botanique played Bishop to f6 locking
down the position here it seems like the
black king is now doomed
you know moves like Queen to c3 Queen c7
are coming but here kappa blanka finds a
very very nice defensive idea simply
king to e8 and now again you have to you
have to try Queen to c3 with some Queen
to c6 ideas but even then Capablanca
could defend with King to d7 but then
again the position would still be
playable for white here after King e8
Bishop to e7 was played and now
Capablanca simply takes advantage of the
position as botanique has given him too
much
we have rook to f5 Queen to c3
but now Queen to c3 isn't all that
powerful King to d7 now Queen to g7 will
not come with any checks as the bishop
is now blocking and not here kappa
blanka
a botanic plays b6 offering the b6 pawn
if you capture it it's not all that
great because now Queen to g7 will
threaten all sorts of discovery so black
would have to be very careful here so
instead Queen to c6 kappa blanka
immediately offers a trade of Queens as
now capablanca is up the exchange so we
have Queen to g7 threatening some
discoveries here but now comes Queen
captures on f3 to avoid the trade of
Queens botany care to allow this
unfortunate move
King h2 we have Queen g3 check King h1
Queen captures on h4 King g1 now comes
Queen e1 check King h2 and now King to
c6 not allowing any discoveries and you
know it's it's a very nice square for
the King here Queen the b2 was played
you can't go
d7 of course not the idea is if you
capture with the King Bishop before
checks checks the king and wins the
Queen here but here black will simply
ignore you simply push f3 and even if
you bring the knight into the game with
check King moves not comes Queen B -
there's really nothing to do here and
now you're getting checkmated check King
moves F to check F 1 Queen checks King
moves another Queen comes into the game
and this will be root F 2 checkmate
so after King to c6 Botnick tries Queen
to be 2 but now rug d5 and now Queen the
C to check a couple Blanca place King to
be 5 and it was in this position that
Botvinnik resigned the game he resigned
because there is nothing to do here
anymore after 1 check in the King hides
on a6 and there is nothing to be done
here
b7 now comes Queen g3 check King moves
and this will be checkmate so a very
interesting game and yeah like we said
botanique Heather had a couple of
chances first that Queeny Queeny 5 idea
instead of immediately capturing and c7
he missed that he wanted he'd her missed
it or he wanted to you know really take
out a couple Blanca with a bank and then
after he also after he after couple one
complained f4 but when it really started
losing time and then then he blundered
on move 40 at you know just at the
moment that he reached time control but
you know such is the way of chess so
yeah a very nice game by both of them a
very nice game by Botvinnik definitely
but it seems that experience is
experienced and Botvinnik definitely
learned a lot from this game so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank a man the field
Dan O'Hanlon David Woodhouse Dani
McCullough and Hassoun Mahoney for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video see are
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon not to be the video but with
my 200000 subscribers celebratory stream
and a nice leaches arena hope to see
everyone there thank you all and see you
soon